so uh i like drawing some curveballs at
the beginning of an interview when i
have a few extra minutes for for both of
you that's terrifying
right
it's easier i feel so unsettled
oh if someone has never seen anything
that you've done
in the past what's the first thing that
you want them watching and why
that's a good question
that's a great question i feel relieved
that that's the question first of all
but um
so actually okay so my the
the thing that i'd love them to watch
because it's the most fun i've ever had
what is burning love with ken with ken
marino who directed it and his wife eric
oyama wrote it
and it you know was just the most fun
i've ever had and it was all improvised
and
kind of run and gun and um
i love love love the character i played
julie gristle white and it's just an
insanely good time
hmm
i love that
i i'd say i don't know i mean it's it
depends on who's walking up to me but
but i'd say like saving women you know
just because
that's just fun
um
i don't know you know i did a little
movie i we just watched it
i hadn't seen it in decades
decades
and um yes i said decades
um
it's called um it was called
freak talks about sex but it's called
now i think they changed it to blowing
smoke
but a little tiny movie that i did up in
upstate new york like sometimes it's
those
i'm really proud of me and josh hamilton
it's amazing
i like those little guys
uh jumping into why i get to talk to you
um do you guys feel a little bit like
were you having a little bit of deja vu
or like a little weirdness when you're
filming this movie in terms of are we
making like the next generations crisp
like christmas story
because like there's a little there's a
lot of energy with that i'm just
comparing obviously the two movies
yeah i think so i mean i i thought that
the you know
i thought it had a lot of that it had it
had a lot of
i mean
you know it's kind of like a western
right you do a christmas
a christmas movie it's about christmas
a western is kind of a retold
uh fable the american myth basically and
so
it's hard to deviate too much from
you know other movies but um
i think it's a it
oh god i don't know what i'm saying june
what do you think you were basically you
were shooting a western while we were
making this see i was in a different
movie so now all of your choices make
sense to me steve
i was so confused and now i understand
you were mentally in a western
um
i
i did well i i read the script and i was
like oh this is it made me laugh made me
cry
i was so
so nostalgic of is so similar to the way
i grew up the character reminded me so
much of my mom
and
yeah it felt like oh it's got that thing
and sometimes that's hard to describe
what that is but that feeling of
um timelessness and
you know something people are going to
return to because the the comedy is
really strong but then it hits
hits in all the right places so
yes when i read the script i thought
this is this is i think this is a
christmas classic for sure
one of the things that i think that's
universal about this movie is that
everybody no matter who you are when
you're a kid there is a toy that you are
desperate to get something that you you
know you you would do anything to
acquire um and so for both of you i'm
sure you've answered this before but
what was that thing when you were a kid
that you're like i will literally cut
off my arm i need this
i was really obsessed with the american
so i was the first generation of girls
who had access to the american girl doll
and i think the book came out first and
i like read the books
crazily and then i really wanted and you
could get you know the american girls
doll girl dolls like they each were set
in a different
era of time and
i looking back i don't know if i should
have done this but i got molly who was
the like 1950s tomboy doll i really
related to her and she wore glasses
and
um
she was really plucky and and smart and
i just loved her and i loved the stories
about her and i was obsessed with her
and
i still have her she's in my children's
room i mean she's now like in a basket
and her hair is in like one giant rat's
nest but she's still among us and i
worked on getting her for christmas for
a solid year
um then i got her
i think uh you know what i wanted i just
thought of this i was trying to
uh a guns in avaron mountain
do you remember it i'm aging myself but
there was a guns in navarone it was a
plastic mountain and it had an elevator
and it had the german gun and it
actually shot what are you saying
yeah you know the guns of navarone the
movie
gregory peck
anyways he was a popular movie and then
they made the playset
and you'd set up your
you set up your army men in it and i
wanted that and i never got it thanks
mom and dad
wow
what's funny is i think every oh sorry
i was just wondering if steve still
still wanted it and if
i mean i guess i could do a google
search steve and see if i could get it
for you you seem you seem really upset
it's pretty cool
my neighbor had it and i didn't
wow
okay
yeah did you have you actually um
actually let me switch to something else
last question for both of you uh i'm a
big fan of big mouth and i just have to
ask you uh june what's it like voicing
devin and steve uh did you notice a lot
of people texting and calling you when
white lotus was on trying to get answers
from you
yes
yeah yeah i was inundated with um
people wanting to know who did what
um
i never texted you so i wasn't one of
those people harassing you
i
well big mouth is so amazing and i
i i remember when i did the first
episode of it i was like oh i'm just
going to come in and do this one thing
and i'll
you know nick nickroll is my a very old
friend of mine i love him so much and
and then the part and the character kind
of kept on coming back and i just i
loved devon
and she's insane and and the worst
person in the world and i love her
dearly you know it's just so much fun
yeah i'm i i love the show i think for
anyone who's watching this interview has
not seen big mouth i strongly recommend
it it is
it's so good um last thing steve i know
you're from kentucky i know you might be
a fan of bourbon or whiskey what's like
the top bourbon or whiskey that you
have to have like what's the one you
always reach for on the shelf
well like go to or or like if i could
like blanton's if i can find it or some
weller you know but like go to
man that
old forester
86 man it's just cheap bourbon but it's
like
good stuff
you're you're i mean i like bourbon and
whiskey and uh you're based in kentucky
is it just as hard to get some of those
bourbons and whiskeys now in kentucky
harder
i shot a movie in montana and went to a
liquor store and i couldn't believe it
and i brought two bottles they had
weller and i brought two bottles and i
was like can i get two and the guy was
like
do you live in kentucky i said yeah i do
he's like i knew it
like you can buy all of them if you want
i was like why don't
[Laughter]
i'm all set
i got i got to stop there i'm just going
to say congrats on the movie and
indulging my uh my questions um have a
great day
thank you
i think you're going to pull out the
weller right now
you